and if there's too many colored people
around here I definitely will get out of
one of the main reasons was because it
was a white community and we understood
that it was going to be all white and we
were very happy to buy a home here
this was Levittown Pennsylvania shortly
after World War two in a suburb that
explicitly promised a white only
neighborhood and it wasn't some outlier
it was the prototypical suburb go by the
father of suburbia bill 11 who created
several suburbs around the u.s. all
named Levittown but one reason Levitt
wanted a white only community was
because the US government was
subsidizing it and that's what they
wanted they said they didn't want
racially in harmonious groups lowering
property values that's why I Leavitt
didn't just sell cookiecutter houses
[Music]
he sold a meticulously crafted
affordable utopian lifestyle so as the
courts integrated public spaces like
schools more and more white people fled
to these suburbs and these patterns are
still the defining characteristic of
America's racial geography but we now
spend most of our time at work and there
it gets a lot more complicated more than
a million program each year
shortly after the first Levittown broke
ground in 1947 in Long Island New York
about 80% of men still commuted the hour
to Manhattan and while neighborhoods
were getting deeply segregated these
workplaces were getting more diverse the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 banned
employment discrimination more companies
explicitly said that they were equal
opportunity employers and segregation
within our workplaces declined this
meant the workplace was a crucial
environment for us to interact with
people of other races
[Music]
except that's not exactly how it turned
out a few months ago researchers at
Cornell and Penn State shared a data set
with me and when I mapped it it kind of
blew my mind this is a map of where
people work in modern-day Chicago the
tolerant area the more people there are
but now let's color in each neighborhood
by the percentage of white people you
can see the city centers are pretty
diverse but now here's what happens when
they go home what's even more astounding
is what happens when we map people of
color here's where black people work in
Chicago again they're concentrated in
diverse city centers but when black
workers go home they go to very
segregated neighborhoods clustered in
poorer areas and we can see the same
patterns in DC Detroit Philadelphia
pretty much everywhere in the US these
maps showed just how stubborn
residential segregation is but they also
show what looks like a clemmer of hope
for integration cities are remarkably
diverse during the work day so this got
researchers interested in looking closer
at what's at work let's look at how
segregation changed in recent years from
2000 to 2010 as an intial segregation
between black and white people got
slightly better for the most part
segregation just mostly plateaued for
all racial groups but when researchers
looked at how segregation changed during
the day when we're at work they found
that segregation increased slightly
across all racial groups when we zoom in
some more to the company level we can
see a bit more of what's actually
happening researchers at Stanford and
Harvard found within a company
segregation levels have gone down very
little in other words we're exposed to
about as much diversity now as we were
as generation
go but there are a lot more people of
color now than there were in 1880
so what's going on well they aren't
being more represented at these white
majority companies which would look like
this rather they're giving opportunities
at companies that are mostly non-white
over here so this means that when we
look at this from a company level
segregation has actually gotten worse
than a generation ago of course some
places are pretty diverse so researchers
looked at what kinds of places actually
have less segregation during the day but
they found that if a place is diverse
during the day it's likely not because
people of all races are working
alongside each other rather it's
probably because most of the higher
status workers like managers are white
and the lower status workers like
janitors are people of color American
policies engineered our segregated homes
but work where we spend most of our time
many thought that could be a space where
we form meaningful relationships with
people of other racial backgrounds
that hasn't quite happened and we see it
in the most personal parts of our lives
in 2014 the Public Religion Research
Institute asked Americans to list the
people with whom they've discussed
important matters in the past six months
in other words our friends most Hispanic
people had friends of other races about
one of three black people did too but
seventy-five percent of white people
only had white friends in short we may
be exposed to diverse spaces but we
still live very segregated lives and the
end it probably will end up with with
mixing socially
[Music]